Bitcoin surging today and back to its
highest price it's April 14th it is now
back above 30 000. the rally being
fueled by news in part that BlackRock
applied for a spot Bitcoin ETF that is
the first of its kind in the market so
Wall Street is sort of getting back or
getting back deeper into the crypto game
this despite what appears to be sort of
a Crackdown by the SEC
how do we Square it from when the story
is bringing crypto Guru and Tech
investor Anthony popliano he's the
founder of pump Investments and the host
of the pump podcast which is not without
circumstance see what I did there
Anthony thanks for joining us your take
how big of a don't don't I'm a dad it's
a dad joke how big of a deal is this
BlackRock ETF
yeah look I think what's happening right
here is uh everyone's heard of the Space
Race where a bunch of countries got
together and they all tried to get the
space first but now what we're gonna see
is the great accumulation race and what
I mean by that is we have institutions
and individuals all scrambling to try to
get their share of the 21 million
Bitcoin that will ever be in existence
the retail investor for 15 years now has
had a head start and they've accumulated
all the Bitcoin that has been actually
mined and put into circulation but 68 of
all of that Bitcoin in circulation
hasn't moved in over a year and so what
that means is when Wall Street people
like BlackRock and other organizations
that have now filed for these ETFs or
other products show up to the market and
they want to buy Bitcoin Bitcoin is a
highly illiquid asset and these
bitcoiners don't want to sell to Wall
Street and so the only thing that can
move when you have a fixed Supply asset
that's highly illiquid and there's a
bunch of demand that comes into the
market is the price has to go up how
long that takes is anyone's guess but I
think that's the big story here is the
great accumulation race is underway
let me flip it a little bit Anthony
because we all know I don't know how old
you are I'm not going to ask it's not
polite but I'll tell you know I do know
this now as a parent once the parents
start getting involved in the cool stuff
that their kids are doing it is no
longer cool parents starts dressing like
the kid no way change it up it appears
you know Bitcoin was kind of always the
decentralized future of money kind of
hard to understand for the uninitiated
the cool kids thing now guess what no
offense to Blackrock maybe the world's
most boring company in some ways is now
adopting it does that hurt Bitcoin in
any way from like a cool standpoint
yeah look I've always said that Bitcoin
sits at this really unique area uh in
finance if I go and I talk to people on
Wall Street and they own Bitcoin they'll
tell me Bitcoin is the riskiest asset in
their portfolio if I then go and I talk
to kind of the crypto community and go
and talk to people who are buying all
sorts of crazy assets they'll tell me
that Bitcoin is Boomer coins the most
boring thing that they have in their
portfolio and me personally as an
investor that's where I want to sit I
want to have the riskiest asset in the
conservative investors portfolio and I
want to have the most conservative asset
in the Risk Takers portfolio and so I
think that BlackRock right now is
realizing if you just bought Bitcoin and
held it since the start of the pandemic
you've outperformed almost every single
hedge fund on Wall Street you just
Bitcoin and chill and I tend to think
that these investors they're not gonna
go put 100 of their assets into Bitcoin
but what they are starting to say is
does this warrant a one two three
percent allocation into a portfolio and
I think that that argument is becoming
much more hard to ignore and so what I
think you're going to start seeing is
that these large asset managers say we
have to have a product in the market
well you know four years ago like almost
to this week I kind of gave a shout out
it wasn't endorsed kind of a fake shout
out to Litecoin right you got Al Goran
you got Solana you got Dogecoin you got
ether how much are you in any of these
ones to your point the more risky ones
the more gambling not boring old Bitcoin
in a way but taking up maybe taking a a
investment risk down that crypto ladder
if you will Anthony
Bitcoin is the king I don't think that's
going to change it's over 50 of the
market today hash rates at an all-time
high if you go and you look at wallet
addresses with 0.1 Bitcoin or one full
Bitcoin hitting all-time highs and I
continue to think that Bitcoin is going
to continue to prove to be the winner in
this market and so if you're somebody
who's looking at the market it's just
like buying the S P 500 Index right you
just want the boring thing that seems to
keep compounding for a long period of
time and it's Timeless investing
principle buy great assets and never
sell them you know it's The King and I
and I'm going to quote the the great
poet philosopher Omar little from The
Wire if you go after the king
better not miss Anthony pompliano do
appreciate it my man thank you very much
thanks for having me